how about my daughter running on the air
assault my arrow cool you cannot look
any older below that the I'm sorry sir
my what happened there it's the face a
lot
well no but that or did you look young
well that's because of my eyes it's my
eyes dude no bro bro you look you see
how my eyes are falling once I get them
look I can have that skin removed I'm
gonna do it and I'm gonna be good
looking but are you gonna do that you
thing my mother said I should do it
because what happens is with her and me
our eyes like she got it done you can't
tell well what happens when your mom is
done yeah the skin fall you have to do
it once in your life there's like some
guy named dan Baker some [ __ ] yeah
there's a million guys who do it yeah
but I mean that's my eyes I got to make
sure I do anything I've been even best
place for cut for plastic surgery in the
world yeah but you know then again I can
always tell when people have plastic
surgery I don't wanna I'm not gonna be
the guy who's like he had his eyes done
at 52 that's embarrassing your eyes done
we don't but I don't know it as I talk
about I'm here but what are you gonna do
just they look like a bloodhound yeah
yeah that's the bra okay they take my
saw me sure you know you're sharp eh
yeah they take this skin okay oh my god
they take the skin and whether they dig
John Travolta and how tight his face is
now hold my gosh dude Berra Singh
don't do that to your looks like he is
old let me see that let me see what
they're gonna do to is I hear severe
eyelid Pierre using front towles sling
have that guy what's wrong with this
Asian dudes eyes see Haitian wait he's
young he's probably a I'm sorry my DS he
not eat where his eyes not Beijing he
might be mixed I wouldn't assume that
use maybe much oh look at a visa you can
close oh yeah desire wait that's what
you want to get done or you want to snip
a couple of wrinkles off the top yeah
you just take some of the skin off and
apparently it's a very very what did you
go to chin
wait yeah I don't have droopy eyes why'd
you go droopy eyelid sir
eyelid excess skin surgery oh that is
excess skin right yeah let's go get
older my eyes have changed I don't you
know do that right that lady looks
exactly the same
yes yeah looks I'd be the same dose
that's right something like that exactly
like that that's what you want to get
done yeah what a waste of time you just
wanna get rid of the hanging skin um
yeah yeah I do you have trouble with
your vision my mother said that I I will
eventually like she she was it was like
she showed me pictures of her I went oh
[ __ ] and then she goes look at my eyes
now and you can't tell and I was like ah
why wouldn't I do that if it cuz it
distracts me because one is drooping
lower so on camera it looks lopsided I
don't like it I I can't believe I'm even
talking about getting plastic surgery on
my face which is cute I know stuff all
guys who do then I'm for sure you know
roast the [ __ ] just do a nose job
though look at it while you're under
while you're under new kenny loggins are
not kenny loggins kenny rogers before
and after we check the space and jetsam
work
oh-ho what Kenny Rogers this is food
Larry I don't hate I hate on anyone who
gets my surgery I just want you to touch
it yeah look at his eyes look at that
come on dude don't get your whole face
tightened you look like him you just
come on I mean yeah you had some teeth
on him though Johnny
that's a job job s you get your teeth
too white you can't do that just just
get old all good and then just do you'll
know it's to snip the nutsacks off your
eyelids yeah you just gotta be careful
with when you go to see the cheek
fillers that's where it gets a little
dicey right just your eyes bro wax that
you see that and the eyes even the eyes
are a little bit of a telltale sign too
though don't get crazy with ya dude do
you think Kenny Rogers [ __ ] all the
girls in the land I think he I don't
know I know he was he could sing his ass
off what's his most famous song The
Gambler maybe but the chin do you know
him I feel like you would realize yeah I
liked his newer stuff
and Wayne Blaney Boyd he know he went he
did so much like surgery he went from
white dude Asian he's out he tied his
face tucked so far back what does he do
they're like you know you're gonna look
like a mix Korean kid right he went just
[ __ ] do it
what is he doing uh-oh hold on just hold
that there hold out there dude show the
show business a [ __ ] you don't
know that you look ridiculous though you
don't know that you look no did she turn
in an old Asian man how does his how
does this doctor how do you how do you
not know that you look absolutely
unacceptable well but yeah but on the
left you don't think he no one told me
look like the Red Baron from the pizza
commercial but you got a gold you gotta
just be like this is who I am not that
[ __ ] guy you seen Mickey Rourke oh I
watch that the losers he was on there
that doesn't count
oh really changes he's wears a wig the
whole thing's a disaster like I that
poor man that's that to me it's mental
to me is more than that's that's more
than vanity there's no Ricky Ricky or
Mickey Rourke has mental sickness I
think he's just in show business see
Mickey Rourke's not trying to look young
but look at his shirt no monster on to
you but look at him look at how
beautiful he was when he was younger
look at that [ __ ] now that's a wig dude
what the [ __ ] is going on dude how about
the what if they're not a doctor either
goes Brown I don't think we should do
this that's what I'm saying
isn't there a doctor goes look you look
like a mask you look like a Halloween
character dude you look like a monster
I mean what the [ __ ] is going on [ __ ] is
that in there oh is that fake it's real
that's him no that's fake that's fake I
think that's real that's real come on
jeez I think that's more of a mental
sickness
oh that muhfuckas great Danny scary I'm
using great a [ __ ] Iron Man 3
oh he's fantastic but as a monster he's
great but what the [ __ ] there what is
going on like he was III I don't know
it's mental sickness bro it is it is
it's mental sickness that's a wig your
a wig sir when I think of Hollywood
that's what I think about not me the
last thing I think about really yeah
[ __ ] no he said he's the hell no I'm
gonna he's the exception me I'm gonna
have to find his doctors and avoid him
30 times fast while talking to you why
wouldn't I give that to you as it's a
gift it's a gift it's a gift